(upbeat rap music)
Ha!
- Cha-ching!
- Hi, I'm Staci Greenbaum
and I'm the Costume
Designer at Broad City.
- Staci has been with
us from the beginning.
- She was sort of
that immediate friend.
- Whoa, I love that outfit.
- Thank you.
- Staci has such a great
balance between looking good,
looking fine, looking bad,
but like I'm not gonna
fully hate myself
while I'm editing.
- For me, it's been like,
well how would the
characters dress?
How am I differentiating
myself from this character?
- [Staci] Abbi typically
does a lot of physical comedy
so whether or not
it caters to that is
usually kind of an
important factor.
We play with color
and pattern and print,
and I'd say that this season,
we've kind of been able to
go the distance on that.
- Know what, I think
I need to change into
something a little more
casual, like resort wear.
- Resort wear?
- Ilana, who's sort of
an occasional dresser.
She likes to be outlandish
and a little wacky.
But we kind of go from
zero to 60 on her.
- Can you remind again why
you asked me to meet you
at what turned out
to be a sex store?
- Because I need a second
opinion on a new leotard.
- Come on, Ilana.
- The process with
Abbi and Ilana has been
extremely collaborative.
- Sometimes we're leading and
then sometimes Staci leads.
- Mm-hmm.
- We just want it to feel real.
When I'm looking
for new inspiration,
I'm also looking to,
sort of, what is the
arc of their life?
Cuz that actually
influences a lot of
the choices that we make.
This is the season
where Abbi and Ilana
are both kind of starting fresh.
- Everyone is gonna see how
freakin' hot you are today,
including you.
(funky music)
- One of my very favorite
pieces from this season,
this jean jacket was
kind of a reference to
a Don King jean jacket.
Also again, a great
collaboration where
we sort of picked
Ilana's brain, like,
"Who are the women that are
important to Ilana Wexler?"
And then we kind
of went from there.
It's really fantastic and
says a lot about Ilana.
- It looked beautiful on
you tonight, so (bleep) me.
- One of the things that's
really fun this season
is that we do a
flashback episode.
- Thanks again
for swiping me in.
- Oh, you're welcome ma'am.
- Well, she did a lot
of research on 2011.
- [Staci] We had to imagine
Abbi and Ilana individually
without the influence
of one another.
One of the trends that we
wanted to bring back for Abbi
was sort of this whole
peasant, free people moment.
And belting things that
truly needed no belting.
- I was always belting
stuff like that.
- Belting, and your
flats were horrible.
- Ugh, you're kidding me.
- Hey.
- Florida was a
big Staci episode.
- So cute.
- We are family now!
- This is an outfit
that Abbi wears
to the condo board
meeting when it's sort of
this big deciding moment.
- Funny thing about the
Florida outfits were like,
we kind of looked cute.
They're not just ridiculous.
- [Staci] There are seven
changes for each of them.
So we really do a
whole runaround.
- Thanks for the
full new wardrobe.
- If fashion is art
that you're wearing,
we are wearing subtle
nuanced comedy.
- The fitting process is
so fun and sort of the way
the girls write really
lend itself to these
really amazing costume moments.
- The dress.
- Hon, do zip me up.
- [Staci] Broad City is
such a dream to work on.
It's something that I relate to,
it's something my
friends relate to.
And I think this
season especially,
with everything that's going
on, it just feels really good
to be part of a
show that encourages
women and really
everyone to just
be better, to do better,
and to support each other.
And that's kind of
what the show's about.
(howling)
(cheering)